special thanks to indeed for sponsoring
a portion of this video when you finally
got the right answer the stars align and
the numbers add up the fastest way to
reach your potential is with the right
people in place if you're hiring you
need indeed with indeed you can attract
interview and hire all in one place
indeed partners with you on every step
of the hiring process so you can find
talent with the skills you need through
tools like indeed instant match
assessments and virtual interviews with
instant match candidates you invite to
apply are three times more likely to
apply to your job than those who only
see it in search according to indeed
data listen get started right now
with a 75
sponsored job credit to upgrade your job
post at indeed.com
talk get a 75 credit indeed.com
starttalk can i say it again
indeed.comtalk
offer valid through december 31st terms
and conditions apply you need to hire
you need indeed
[Music]
that time again chuck
yes
okay i'm trying to i'm excited to know
what we've got going today we're going
to just talk about oxygen
oh man
what's the matter
dude normally you come to me with some
like super exciting stuff like
today we're going to talk about the moon
and albedo do you know what albedo is no
man what is that that sounds great i'm
sure i'm sorry oxygen doesn't excite you
but maybe by the end of these 10 minutes
it will that's all i'm saying all right
give it a chance give it well listen i
give oxygen a chance every day
okay
okay
many people who have never had
atmospheric chemistry
right they know that we breathe oxygen
for to survive we know this right but
not
everyone knows how much oxygen is in our
atmosphere
okay well okay all ready now i'm
interested right so the first guess is
well it's all oxygen right of course
we're breathing that's not the case
right most of the air we breathe is
nitrogen nitrogen okay which has no
value in its gaseous form as we inhale
it so we just inhale it and then exhale
it
okay
nitrogen is 78 of the air we breathe
wow it's most most
did not know that did not know that okay
so now
oxygen is between 20 and 21
of the air we breathe so it's about a
fifth of the air we breathe
all right
right so just let me put that out there
first of all
second
as you know trees and other
photosynthesizing life makes oxygen
right
one of the the the delusions of the star
trek the early star trek series
was
they yep you ever noticed i've said this
in other explainers they never wear
spacesuits when they visit planets every
time they come down to a planet they're
just like whoa isn't this nice
no so they check it's oxygen nitrogen
atmosphere okay it's a class m planet
right so then they go down it's got
oxygen right as though
in the mix of all the planets that are
out there
some of them will just happen to have
this mix and so it'll be just fine to be
human and then walk down on its surface
okay
all right
but if you think it through the entire
source of our oxygen
is green plants
if you take away the green plants oxygen
is highly reactive
as a chemical element and so the oxygen
that's in the atmosphere will glom on
to other ingredients on earth's surface
and it will systematically drain
out of the earth's atmosphere
leaving us with none
so if you find a planet that has
sustained oxygen
right
that is evidence
of something generating that oxygen and
in our case it's plants that may could
be some other mechanism none we have
ever dreamt of or divined but
if you find a planet with oxygen it's
going to have plant life
wow
right
or something that is generating oxygen
in real time and in the planets they
went to that was never discussed because
i think they just believed in the planet
lottery some planets have oxygen and
others don't and you know what's funny
that you say that
many of the planets that they beam down
to
were
very
mars-like
they're very
rocky
there's not there's no vegetation at all
i think the rocks are easier for the
prop people to make
than whole trees with plumage right yeah
it was very barren correct you
remembered this so that's one little
thing about the oxygen put out there
okay
also by the way on the planets they
landed on they were never sort of
bounding the way the astronauts did on
the moon those planets all had about one
g just like earth
yes
and the atmospheric pressure was about
that of earth that same as earth there
are some planets that are the same size
as earth and the same gravity as earth
but the atmospheric pressure is a
hundred times that of earth so they beam
down and just get flat and flat like a
like they got hit with a fly swatter
yeah basically
wow
yeah okay so
more about oxygen
there's this
belief
oxygen is flammable
okay
that's because every oxygen tank i've
ever seen has the word flammable
written all over it
that might be why people believe that
you go to any hospital you're going to
see a tank you'll see a tank in the
corner and on that tank it's going to be
a little fire emoji with the word
flammable
is that what's on text emojis i didn't
know that
all right
so
so
um
i should clarify
what's going on there okay okay
oxygen
promotes combustion
that's why they have those labels there
so
if you this
won't happen today ever but in the day
you walk into a hospital smoking a
cigarette
if you go into a hospital room
wait a minute now i'm just seeing a
doctor
smoking smoking a cigarette scalpel
with them with a hole through the mask
scalpel wait let me quarterize this
exactly oh god ah there we go oh jesus i
think i dropped my butt in this guy's
open
abdomen
anybody seen a cigarette butt
and you've got this smoker's voice too
exactly
oh my god your doctor sounds like a
diner waitress well listen dear
i don't want to give you bad news
but
here's the load here's the lowdown hun
let me get you a coffee and then we'll
talk about this
the smoking new york diner diner
oh man okay all right so so here's what
i have it promotes combustion so
if you're in a room of oxygen
and you bring in a lit cigarette
the cigarette would
instantly go up in smoke wow
instantly i mean it would go from the
lit spot but and the whole thing would
just ignite instantly that's good but
you're not going to ignite the gas in
the room that's my point
aha
the oxygen itself
does not burn so oxygen
because no i was about to say it's like
a non-burning accelerant
okay i can yes sure i mean that's i'm
trying to make sense of this because
i'll allow that but i think in
firefighter talk accelerant accelerant
burns might mean something else right so
uh this is what happened apollo 1.
apollo 1.
all right nobody's ever heard of apollo
1 because it never went anywhere it was
that through apollo 6 i think it was was
a set of designs of the capsule that
would take three astronauts to the moon
there they are
on the launch pad testing on a testing
pad
in the capsule is pure oxygen
whoa here's why
because if they had an oxygen nitrogen
mix
you would have to pressurize the inside
to equal atmospheric pressure right so
that you have the right amount of oxygen
that you're accustomed to breathing if
you do that you have to over build the
strength of the capsule right to contain
one atmospheric pressure against the
vacuum of space gotcha
so all the joints the bolts and the
hinges and the door closures and the
windows would have to be extra strong
so they said why burden ourselves with
this
let's instead
put in pure oxygen
then we don't need to have to have it at
full pressure
that's actually kind of brilliant it's
brilliant it's brilliant now we can
create much lower pressure but it's all
oxygen so now you take in a breath
it's less total air but it's the right
amount of oxygen right that your body is
expecting okay
all right
in that capsule there was an electrical
fire
oh
there was a spark
that immediately burned all of the
insulation the thing their suits
and they could not open the hatch in
time all three astronauts
were burned to death oh
gosh
yep
that is just awful yeah it's terrible
it's it so
again it's it's accidents like that
where we think the oxygen was burning
but that's not what was burning the
oxygen enabled everything burnable
to burn
in a burn the astronauts themselves
correct we lost three astronauts
in that fire damn that is
oh my god that's just terrible right
right so now what did they do to
listen because let me just tell you let
me just say this
first of all it's a tragedy and i would
dare never uh uh infringe upon the
sanctity of those men and write lies but
i will say this
if i'm the next three astronauts i just
quit the space program okay no no here's
what they did instead of saying okay
let's try apollo 2. okay no what they
did was they scrapped six apollo designs
and came up with the paul seven i think
it was seven or eight no apollo seven
and so
they were nowhere near what that design
was by the time they had the next vessel
in place okay
all right that would have satisfied you
i think yeah so anyway so that's another
thing with auction here's another one
you're ready in the movie jaws
okay
there's a tank of oxygen yes
on deck
at the end right
and the captain i think uh richard
dreyfuss character bumps into it he's
watch out
that's oxygen okay
all that mattered for the movie
was that what was in the tank was
compressed gas right but they're saying
watch out it's oxygen right oxygen
so what happens how do they finally
defeat the great white shark
okay i forgot which it's been a while
since i've seen the film one of them i
think while the shark is munching on the
boat takes that oxygen tank and shoves
it into the mouth of the shark right
then
dives off the boat
i'm making some of this up because i
don't remember the details but the shark
you can see the tank in the shark's
mouth the guy takes his high-powered
rifle
shoots the tank and the tank explodes
blowing the head of the shark off and
then peace
reigns right in nantucket or wherever
the hell this was yep okay
so what mattered there was not that it
was oxygen but that it was gas under
pressure and when you punched a bullet
hole in it probably it just would have
been a hole it would have gone
i was going to say the shark should have
just shot off into the distance yeah he
would have had a little little retro
rocket a little rocket mouth
his rocket mouth now and it's just like
so that's probably what would have
happened um but
if this tank is not structurally sound
and it can't accommodate a hole it could
conceivably blow up but it blew up not
because it had oxygen in it
right because gas under pressure
so that's different from if you leave
your gas and your stove on and all your
windows are closed and you go out and
you come back right now there's gas
everywhere in the house a spark
right
won't just burn what sparked the all the
gas
will now ignite and explode and that's
the difference between methane gas which
is flammable and oxygen gas which is not
right right and you know and the other
difference is normally that's kind of
like um insurance fraud but oh yes yes
okay
in the old days i don't know if there's
as much of that uh today yeah they got
too much uh forensic science too much
science yeah too much science it's your
people your people screwed it up
we can science the [ __ ] out of whatever
you just did
right i can't collect the insurance from
my failing business now thanks to you
but you guys ass in jail
so a couple more things
okay
um as you may know
plant life
likes carbon dioxide of course it
absorbs it
okay and that carbon becomes part of the
fibers of the wood
and
out comes oxygen
which we breathe
okay
if you have too much plant life
and it creates let's call it excess
oxygen
okay let's say
30 oxygen in the atmosphere
and i there are calculations that do
this which i can't quote precisely but
just some number above the 21 that we
now have right take it to 30 40 50
oxygen imagine a world where plants are
just pumping this out and they're loving
it okay
in that world
forest fires never end
oh that makes sense because they have
they have they're being fed by oxygen
all the time by oxygen correct so
there's a fuel of the wood and then the
oxygen is also
you know fueling it too so in a way it's
self-correcting
too much plant life creates too much
oxygen so the next lightning strike
will take it out
preventing more oxygen from coming in
well it's it's it's it's own check and
balance correct correct
so it's just interesting to think about
how you end up pegging oxygen at one
level versus another
interesting one other thing and i think
we talked about it in our surface area
explainer
insects
don't
most of them don't have lungs the way we
think of we breathe in we have lungs and
that's how we get our oxygen insects
many of them rely on
absorbing oxygen through their surface
right right
okay which is why they never need breath
mints but that's right is that right
thank you for telling me okay so they
and so
if you have more oxygen in your air
this is like rocket fuel for them
wow and they can grow bigger
oh
because when you're bigger your surface
area to volume is lower
but if you have we could we did that in
an explainer you have to dig that one up
if you're bigger you have more volume to
your surface area so now you're not
going to get enough oxygen to feed your
fat body but if the oxygen levels are
higher you can
and so that's why you had those huge
dragonflies back at the time of the
dinosaurs right okay oxygen levels were
higher back then you had these huge
insects
so
oxygen levels have consequences in the
biota
of earth nice
wow so who knew
that all of this
who knew all this about o2
exactly exactly and oxygen wants to
combine and so it combines with itself
best so you have an o2 oxygen and one
last thing
people talk about humans
wrecking the earth uh you know the only
species ever to change the ecosystem of
the earth that is just false
um the creature that had the greatest
effect
on the climate and conditions of the
earth were the cyanobacteria
of when was this three and a half
billion years ago something like that at
that time earth's atmosphere was mostly
carbon dioxide
hardly any oxygen at all
they taken carbon dioxide
and spew out oxygen
wow
and they built the oxygen
supply of our atmosphere to levels
that were caustic
to animals
that don't like oxygen right so this
killed off
entire branches of the tree of life
who were doing just fine in their carbon
dioxide atmosphere but it enabled other
forms of life to rise up
that would exploit the oxygen for their
own benefit wow
wow
so why can't we just use cyanobacteria
as a carbon scrubber
for our current situation where we have
to mitigate the amount of carbon in the
atmosphere yeah that's that's a good
um
okay so
sure
you have to watch out for unintended
consequences right because guess what we
already saw one unintended consequence
of cyanobacter thanks cyanobacteria
[Laughter]
you know i mean it's uh who knows that
we get should probably get people to
look into that to have biological co2
scrubbers which is what plants are right
right but again they're putting more
oxygen in the air and that also has
consequences so
yeah
wow that was great anyhow
you got it dude i started off saying
oxygen was boring but uh
you know i was raw yeah and by the way
if oxygen were actually flammable
every time you lit a match it would just
burn
your air would burn out
that would be
absolutely kind of cool or you could
just pump oxygen through your through
the gas right uh your gas stove but no
we don't because it's not flammable
that's all i got to tell you about
oxygen
yo that was enough
that's enough that was enough to hey yo
i love it all right dude that was yet
another explainer always good to have
you there chuck always
we need you to bring some levity to what
comes out of my mouth um so all right a
bit of star talk explainer
stuff you thought you knew
neil degrasse tyson
signing out or
keep looking up
that's my sign
[Music]